die Kinder sie sind vor allem jetzt die
notleidenden ich habe es eingangs
bereits gesagt fast 10 Millionen
Deutsche liegen derzeit flach Grippe
Erkältung dass er es Virus die
Kinderkliniken laufen voll Kleinkinder
wenn abgewiesen viele Apotheken haben
nicht mal mehr Fiebersaft die Berliner
Charité hat alle verschiebbaren
Operationen jetzt bis Jahresende
abgesagt und viele fragen sich hat uns
der maskenzwang diese Krankheitswelle
beschert ja das sagt Jakob Maske
Sprecher des Berufsverbands der Kinder
und jugendärzte besonders die kleinsten
hätten nicht die Möglichkeit gehabt ihr
Immunsystem zu trainieren ist
Familienministerin Christina Schröder
betont das Schulkinder weit mehrmals
getragen mussten als die meisten
Erwachsenen sie sagt jetzt sollte sich
herausstellen dass wir ihn
gesundheitlich geschadet haben dann muss
ich der Staat bei unseren Kindern
entschuldigen
was haben wir unseren Kindern da angetan
also ich bin jetzt in den corona-thema
muss ich gegangen nicht so drin und habe
auch diese ganze Schulgeschichte ich
habe das immer nur von außen verfolgt
und kann mich da eigentlich nicht so
engagieren wenn das wirklich so ist dass
er natürlich eine Medien gelesen dann
finde ich muss man den tatsächlich
nachgehen weil man hat ja immer die
Kinder als Unbekannte gehabt die sollten
zwar alles machen was getragen zu Hause
bleiben aber wir wussten nicht erkranken
sie auch und wenn sie jetzt über eine
Hintertür sie gehört mal als
supersprecher sogar deswegen
finde ich also auf jeden Fall aufgeklärt
werden würde ich sagen
in der Apotheke da gibt's nicht mehr
mehr Fieber Säfte Kinder werden
teilweise 40 Kilometer weit weggefahren
weil sie im Krankenhaus nicht behandelt
werden weil die Intensivstation in der
volllaufen ist das auch ein Versagen ein
krankes Gesundheitssystem
ich glaube im deutschen
Gesundheitssystem ist sehr vieles
ungesund und es ist wahrscheinlich krank
und ich finde es ganz bemerkenswert wie
viel Geld eigentlich doch in diesem
System steckt welche welche Milliarden
Summen da eigentlich umgesetzt werden
nur offensichtlich landen sie ja nicht
dort wo sie wo sie gebraucht werden und
ich glaube dass Deutsch
Gesundheitssystem leidet an einer
gefährlichen Mischung aus einer Art
versuchten Marktwirtschaft dass man
versucht manches durch mehr
Privatisierung durch mehr Wettbewerb
kosteneffizient zu lösen auf der anderen
Seite aber doch eine staatliche
Steuerung hat durch eine Bürokratie bei
der vielfältigste Adresse
Interessenverbände auch eine Rolle
spielen wo glaube ich einfach einiges
grundsätzlich im Magen liegt und es
zeigt sich jetzt am Beispiel der
Kinderkrankenhäuser aber ich glaube das
äh das ist auch nur die Spitze eines
Eisbergs es ist auch eine total
dramatische Lager herrgassen auch im
Familienausschuss ich habe gerade gesagt
Christina Schröder sagt wenn das so ist
dass wir auch durch die Masken und die
ganzen Maßnahmen unsere Kinder jetzt in
diese Situation gebracht haben dann muss
ich der Staat entschuldigen sehen Sie
das auch so ich kann das medizinisch
nicht beurteilen ob das einen Masken
liegt wir machen uns im
Familienausschuss vor allem Gedanken
darum was muss man jetzt tun da sind
einmal die Gesundheitsexperten gefragt
was im klinischen Bereich gemacht werden
kann dass Kinder auch gut versorgt
werden in unseren Krankenhäusern und wir
in der Familienpolitik machen uns
Gedanken was wir tun können dass die
Kinder die durch die lockdowns in den
Schulen viele Chancen verpasst haben
viele
bildungs-teile bekommen haben dass das
möglichst schnell wieder aufgeholt
werden kann dazu werde ich ja nachher
auch mein Thema haben da bin ich fitter
als beim Thema zu beurteilen was das für
medizinische Auswirkungen hat ja schon
längst beurteilt das wird von Virologen
beurteilt das wird von Ärzten beurteilt
und es gibt viele Experten die sagen das
Immunsystem der Kinder konnte nicht
trainiert werden dadurch haben sich
Infekte die sich sonst jeden Winter
holen eben aufgestaut und deswegen
kommen wir jetzt geballt auf die Kinder
zu es scheint also diesen Zusammenhang
zu geben und man muss ja auch sagen das
ist eine Tatsache die Kinder haben viel
mehr Maske tragen müssen als die
Erwachsenen die Schulen man konnte nur
mit Maske reingehen das galt in der
Firma am Arbeitsplatz dann oft nicht
mehr also die Kinder haben besonders
gelitten in dieser Pandemie waren wir ja
dann für Sie der Punkt gekommen dass Sie
dem zustimmen würden was Christina
Schröder sagt wann wäre der Punkt
gekommen dass sie sagen ja stimmt da
brauchen wir eine Entschuldigung ich bin
mir sicher wir müssen es aufarbeiten
danach wissenschaftlich woran hat es
gelegen damit wir in Zukunft keine
Fehler machen jetzt ist wichtig dass wir
uns drum kümmern dass die Kinder akut
medizinisch gut versorgt werden in den
äh die Lage in den Kinderkrankenhäusern
im Griff ist und Eltern ich bin frisch
Papa geworden sich keine Sorgen machen
müssen oder keine zu großen Sorgen
machen müssen was ist wenn man Kind
krank ist und sich sicher sein können
dass es gut versorgt wird das wünschen
sich mit Sicherheit alle
Eltern alle Menschen auch sonst Herr
Schiller was ist ihr Eindruck es war so
dass die kleinsten ja vor allem auch in
die Verantwortung gezogen wurden um die
Älteren zu schützen jetzt kann man den
Eindruck gewinnen jetzt wenn sie im
Stich gelassen also ich würde jetzt
gerne einfach mal so ein Stück auf die
Metaebene gehen und fragen was ist das
schief gelaufen und da frage ich mich
wie wird Politik heute noch gemacht
machens die Politiker machen es
sogenannte Sachverständige und Experten
und wir haben ja alle noch die vielen
Talkshows in Erinnerung zum Thema Virus
Schule Beruf und so weiter und ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen
durcheinander geraten also dieser misch
Macht zwischen einerseits
Expertenmeinung dann findet man das aber
nicht gut dann nimmt man einen anderen
Experten und am Schluss kommt irgendeine
Entscheidung raus und die Ergebnisse
sehen wir jetzt gerade das ist ja nicht
die einzige falsche Entscheidung die
getroffen worden ist nicht glaube
ich würde jetzt lieber das Ergebnis
sagen ich glaube man muss hingehen und
muss noch mal fragen wie soll zukünftig
Politikberatung stattfinden damit wir
bessere und validere Entscheidung
treffen können denn sowas darf nicht
noch mal passieren es würde mich
trotzdem interessieren welche Punkte
wollten sie dann noch oder welche sind
da noch in ihrem Kopf wenn sie sagen es
wurden viele falsche Entscheidungen
getroffen also ich beispielsweise bin
voll darauf reingefallen auf die
Impfpflicht ich dachte das ist eine gute
Idee weil wenn etwas hilft dann impfen
aber inzwischen stellt sich ja heraus
dass impfen hilft einem selbst aber es
hilft nicht dagegen dass man den Virus
weiterträgt so und ich finde das ist ein
ein weiteres Beispiel dafür wie hilflos
wir uns in diese Krise begeben haben und
deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir eine
neue Art von Politikberatung was
wünschen sie sich da genau das ist
entspannendes Thema wir wollen ja alle
ich glaube das ein uns wahrscheinlich
hier in einem Tisch sitzen das so etwas
nicht mehr passiert für die Kinder kommt
zu spät so treiben müssen wir das würde
sagen weil für die kommt zu spät die
Kinderstationen laufen voll und die
Kinder so bin ich mir sicher haben am
meisten gelitten in dieser Krise was
glauben Sie was müsste passieren dass
solche Fehler nicht noch mal passieren
eine andere Beratung ja ich glaube wir
brauchen Experten die dann da sind wenn
sie benötigt werden hier hat man ja bei
der viruskrise festgestellt man man
nimmt sich den der in der Uni am
nächsten ist hier in der Hauptstadt hat
man einen Professor gefunden dann ein
Professor an Bonn und und und ich glaube
das das hat gezeigt wie wenig
vorbereitet wir auf so etwas wie eine
Pandemie waren und deshalb wäre es ganz
wichtig dass ein Gesundheitsministerium
aber auch ein Familienministerium ein
Verkehrsministerium feste
Expertengruppen schafft die sich mit der
Zukunft befassen und nicht mit der
Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit und das
ist glaube ich ein Appell der
berücksichtigt werden können Sie dieses
Appell hat hier Bundesregierung sich
teilweise auch Experten gesucht und
andere Meinungen von anderen Experten
einfach nicht hören wollen also ich
finde den Aufruf der da dahinter steckt
sehr gut weil sie ja sagen wir sollten
kommen zu einer
produktiven politischen
Auseinandersetzung wo man sich um die
besten Lösungen streitet und gemeinsam
die besten Lösungen sucht sich gut
beraten lässt von Experten und überlegt
gute Entscheidungen trifft ich glaube
das tut auch unsere
Demokratieentwicklung sehr gut wenn wir
uns darauf verständigen dass ja dass wir
so ein bisschen Alarmismus rausnehmen
und uns vielleicht auch mal selbst in
der Krise Zeit nehmen gut über Lösungen
nachzudenken ich glaube wir hatten in
der Pandemie sogar Glück also die was
die expertenlage angeht also die
Experten bestätigen würden
aber ich glaube in ihrer Meinung dann
eher einen Rand gedrängt oder gerade am
Anfang der Pandemie war ja schon eine
große Expertise im RKI da und
große weltweit anerkannte
Wissenschaftler waren zufällig deutsche
und ich glaube dass da schon am Anfang
der Erkenntnis Erkenntnisgewinns viel
Sachverstand da war wie man dann danach
damit umgegangen ist und ob man ihn
wirklich immer gut nur produktiven
politikfindung eingesetzt hat ist eine
andere Frage aber ich glaube wir haben
schon auch gute Experten und
Wissenschaftler weiterhin direkt was
dazu sagen wir sprechen jetzt
wahrscheinlich von von Herrn Professor
Christian Thorsten der der wirklich eine
Kapazität auf dem Gebiet der
coronavirenforschung ist aber das große
Problem ist er ist ein Mann aus dem
Labor der weiß wie man ein Virus zerlegt
und eventuell sogar auch wenn man einen
einen bastelt das ist ja auch so ein
Problem dass dieses Virus ich würde
sagen sogar mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
aus dem Chinesischen Labor stammte und
das auch Leute während am Anfang der
Pandemie vertuschen oder zumindest
kleinreden wollten diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit Herr Drosten ist aber
überhaupt kein Experte davon wie man
eine solche in der Gesellschaft oder so
eine Erkrankung die sich die sich als
pandemieter entpuppt wie man die in der
Gesellschaft als Gesamtgebilde sinnvoll
eindämmt davon hat er einfach würde ich
fast sagen fast zu wenig Ahnung wie ich
aber er wurde zum Erklären für allem wie
man das Coronavirus bekämpft und Leute
die das ein bisschen ähm die für
vernünftigere ganzheitlichere Maßnahmen
liegt plädiert haben und z.B nach
Schweden verwiesen haben die wurden
jetzt zu Beginn der Pandemie die wurden
ja fast so als würden Sie jetzt unsere
alten als würden sie einen ein
Massenmord in unseren Altenheim
veranstalten
zum Beispiel zum Beispiel den den
Professor Streck zum Beispiel auch im
Virologe aber jemand der der nicht nur
im Labor forscht sondern der erste
rausgegangen ins Feld der hat ja das war
ja genau das was sind wir wohl der wurde
ja dann wirklich die Familie aufs
Übelste und zwar auch von Herrn Thorsten
dass er Drosten scheint für mich auch
eine sehr alte Person zu sein der ist
sehr genossen hat dass er dann auf
einmal der Erlöser ist und ähm das das
das das war ungesund das gab keine
offene Debatte weder in der Politik noch
unter Experten in Deutschland und ich
würde nicht sagen dass wir jetzt nur
noch vorne gucken müssen wir müssen
natürlich auch dieses teilweise versagen
und die Fehler die gemacht wurden da da
anprangern und da gibt's noch einiges
aufzuarbeiten es gibt auch einen großen
Teil der Bevölkerung in Deutschland und
zwar sind das auch diejenigen die
vielleicht eher skeptisch waren und sich
nicht sofort impfen lassen haben wollen
die haben auch eine wirklich Wut im
Bauch und eine Unzufriedenheit mit mit
unseren politischen System und den
zuliebe und damit auch mit der ganzen
Gesellschaft zu Liebe muss das auf den
Tischen aufgeklärt werden und dann kann
man nach vorne schauen aber jetzt zu
sagen wir haben jetzt anderes zu tun und
so mal weiter also dass das damit kommt
man glaube ich nicht durch das habe ich
auch so nicht gemeint sondern ich glaube
das
habe ich so auch nicht gemeint ich habe
gemeint wir müssen schauen dass wir was
produktives draus lernen und eben auch
vor Ort keine offene Debatte
das also ich glaube auch dass die
Debatte die wir geführt haben rund um
Corona nicht immer produktiver
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
gehöre zu den sehr nachsichtigen Leuten
die eigentlich fanden dass am Anfang die
Regierung finde ich viele Fehler gemacht
haben zum Beispiel das am Anfang keine
Masken da waren aber ich habe eigentlich
den großen Vorsprung gegeben es war eine
ganz neue Krankheit es war am Anfang
eine Gefahr aus China Italien New York
wo wo wo man einfach nicht wusste ob es
noch noch gefährlicher ist als
gefährlich wo man sich dann hat auch in
viele Sachen glaube ich reinreißen
lassen das ist dann auch sind dann auch
die Medien ja die Bilder aus Peking wo
alles abgeschottet oder aus wohan dass
das hat man sich dann vielleicht zum
Vorwurf gemacht zum Vorbild genommen
also ich bin da etwas nachsichtiger
und habe gedacht eigentlich hatte die
Bundesregierung glaube ich nicht dass
ein schlechte im Sinn zumindest am
Anfang und ich fand auch die Impfpflicht
eigentlich wenn ich ihn Pflicht aber die
Impfungen in der tolle nach einem Jahr
dass sie da war und da sind aber eben
nicht alle in der Gesellschaft
mitgegangen und dann hat es natürlich
offenbar Gräben gegeben wo einige
ausgegrenzt wurden und so weiter dass
das aber vom ganz vom Grunde her war ich
da eher so dass ich gedacht habe das
wäre also ich bin da einfach nicht so
kritisch
gelandet und ich gebe auch zurück bin
ich in die Niederung was alles schief
gelaufen ist dann eingedrungen sondern
ich ich war dann mir so ein Corona
scharf
gebe ich zu ähm ja also ich bin auch
geimpft die hatte auch keine
Nebenwirkung ich ich hatte Corona bis
heute nicht
Ewigkeiten zu Hause verbracht Aufträge
Vorträge alles weggefahren also ich
glaube schon zu den Betroffenen als
freie Autorin aber ähm ich habe ganz
viele Freunde die mir also ganz die
schlimmsten Videos geschickt haben und
ich ich weiß wirklich auch bis heute
nicht aber vielleicht haben die Recht
vielleicht Wahnsinn viele Sachen falsch
gelaufen also ich ich möchte es wirklich
am Ende nicht verurteilen
Abstand dazu zu kriegen und auch bei
gewissen Diskussionen einfach nicht
teilzunehmen oder die auszublenden aber
jetzt sind wir drei Jahre später immer
mehr dass viele Corona die angeblichen
Corona Leugner und die ganz große Gegner
waren der höre ich jetzt in vielen
Medien wenn ich das so lese das in
vielen Sachen doch vielleicht recht
hatten mit einigen die Kritiker also
mehrere Regierungs treu und ähm
habe ich auch viele anfallenden gekriegt
wiederum von der Szene nämlich aber ich
denke mal dass das ist richtig eine
Nacharbeitung sollte so sein dass also
wo die Kritiker Recht hatten finde ich
sollte das auch im Nachhinein anerkannt
werden und ich umgekehrt würde ich mir
wünschen dass die Gesellschaft wieder
etwas mehr an der Stelle zusammen weg es
ist eigentlich
das Besondere Leute die diskriminiert
wurden
und so weiter ich hoffe dass die
Gesellschaft da sind wie ich finde es
zusammen ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema
das Blick auf die lange Bank geschoben
werden darf darüber ähnlich wie ein
Thema über das wir jetzt auch sprechen
wollen auf die lange Bank geschoben
wurde nämlich die Stromversorgung in
Deutschland mit Kriegsausbruch wurde
relativ schnell klar Deutschlands wirken
Energieproblem bekommen dennoch die
Atome Ausstieg der ist beschlossene
Sache die drei AKWs die sind im
streckenbetrieb und sie sagen wenn wir
so weitermachen dann wird's Wetter kalt
und auch dunkel vielleicht dann schon zu
Weihnachten Ihre Kamera